remember we've got a new special offer
if you subscribe to the spectator
magazine today get
10 weeks of the spectator in print and
online
for the price of one with a free bottle
of pims worth
25 pounds thrown in there too that's 10
weeks of the magazine delivered to your
door
and a bottle of pims all for just 4
pound 95.
hurry though this offer ends on the
so-called freedom day
19th of july if you want to take it up
go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer
[Music]
so we have a watered-down freedom day on
the 19th does
the data justify this joining me now is
professor tim spector principal
investigator on the zoe app
tim thanks for joining me to start there
were more than 42 thousand
cova cases reported on wednesday but the
rate at which these cases are rising
is trending downwards and the number of
people dying from the virus
is far lower than what we were
experiencing in previous waves
are you convinced that the link between
cases and severe illness from this virus
has been sufficiently broken
i believe the link has been
not completely broken but virtually
broken so that
the rise in cases is is no longer
scene in deaths and hospitalizations and
i think we're moving into this a new era
in in covid in that regard
and i think we need to start looking at
other parameters
of the infection rather than
this out-of-date look at
deaths in particular which isn't really
helping us
so you've talked about entering this new
phase of the pandemic
and your focus is on new problems of
cold symptoms and also long covered
so what do you think we should be
focusing on now i think we need to
realize that we're gonna
we're still gonna get large numbers of
people infected
uh the data from the zoe app today
is is actually showing that we're
crossing over into having more people
with infections having had a vaccine
than
unvaccinated for the first time and so
this is very much a new era
in the disease as in a way the
unvaccinated population is like running
out of susceptible people
who haven't been infected and they were
mainly the younger ones
and we're getting back this this larger
group of people have been vaccinated
which small proportion
are getting a mild disease and
this means that
the idea that vaccination is a complete
cure if you like for the diseases has to
be reevaluated
having said that it's much milder and we
have the other problem of
long covered and that is still in the
unvaccinated quite a
significant proportion of young people
about one percent
are getting debilitating symptoms at
three months that prevent them
going back to the normal function and
we're seeing
about 500 to 700 estimated cases a day
of that and that should be the parameter
that should be discussed
by the media not really deaths anymore
is the reason that you think we don't
need to focus on the death metric as
much now because you think that it's
going to be
uh one that stays low you think that and
that aspect of the pandemic sadly you
know the worst
outcome that you would die from this
disease is one that is now more or less
under control
i do believe that yes i think deaths are
not going to go suddenly out of control
um there might be some other
deaths as we go into winter again as we
combine with flu
but i don't think this is going to be
worse than you know a bad flu winter
rather than anything else so as long as
we have a a plan
to keep booster vaccinations going
in the very vulnerable and that
occurs well and there's no major shifts
in the in the variants
then i'm i'm not very worried about
deaths as the main
outcome and you're talking about
long coverage uh you know it's it's a
very frightening idea that one would be
debilitated
from having this virus for 10 days two
weeks and then you know potentially have
months if not a
lifetime of consequences of that
but one of the problems is we just still
don't know a lot about long cove but
exactly how one goes about
diagnosing it you know what it means for
somebody if if they do receive that
diagnosis
is this because our priorities haven't
been in the right place for some time
and we haven't been putting enough
emphasis
on long or is this just generally very
difficult
to go about diagnosing and finding out
about viral fatigue that can come
from all sorts of viruses i think it's a
mixture of both
i think that you've got to realize that
with any new disease or new set of
symptoms it does take
usually years to try sorting them out
and working out
which which ones go with which
type of disease what the prognosis is
we really haven't got long term data
to to help us and also i think that
most governments around the world have
been focused on
deaths of their citizens as
as the main priority and keeping the
hospitals going
rather than this longer term public
health problem
which is what's going to be engaging
people from now on so
i think it's a combination of that lack
of priority
lack of setting up studies early on and
and the actual inherent difficulties in
studying something that
as you said does occur with with most
viruses to some extent
that there is a residual tail and
this is no exception and other than the
fact that
the symptoms are particularly uh
striking and
and often uh very long lasting so
i think we do have a problem we do need
a lot more data on this
we're still very deprived of it and
we don't know all the effects of the
immune boosters vaccinations on long
covered
we still haven't done some crucial
obvious studies in long covert
there should have now been a study of
steroids or dexamethasone
in this by now and it it's it's
surprising that hasn't been done
and uh other methods haven't really been
tried so
i i i think we we're in a in a place now
we have to recognize this is
probably the you know one of the major
public health problems
that is gonna have an impact on the nhs
and
we need to many more resources than we
are putting into it at the moment
well we already have uh five million
people on waiting lists the new health
secretary sachi jabba thinks it could go
up to 13 million in the coming months
so certainly something that could
burden the health service further if we
take all of this into account especially
looking at what you call the new phase
taking into account
uh long covet as well what do you make
of the reopening that's been announced
on the 19th of july are you broadly in
favor of it or do you think that it's
too carefree i'm broadly in favor
i think there has to come a time when
you realize you can't keep people locked
up
and you can't keep telling everyone what
to do
and constraining their their liberties
and you have to balance that
the opening up with the benefits the
economy
which has major health impacts and of
course
uh try and encourage people who have
preventable diseases from
not just staying at home with them but
actually coming and up to hospitals and
feeling that
they're safer to come out and get
treated
because um you know the the the
collateral damage from people not
getting
cancer treatments or getting diagnosed
are horrendous really because already we
had won the worst records in europe for
cancer and this is just going to make it
worse so
also realizing that with the phase of
the i think it signals
definite change in the phase of the
disease as we move
to pandemic to endemic
and there'll still be lots of disease
going around we're never going to get
zero covered
and we are moving to milder disease as
long as
people get vaccinated so i think that's
an
important message that this uh
these lifting restrictions which have
been gradual people seem to think it's
all happening on one day but it's not
really
the google mobility data show that
you know people are back at about 85
percent of
uh normal anyway already now
so it's not like it's going from zero to
a hundred percent
and i think the only area i
i'm happy and i was unhappy with was
that
things like public transport and major
crowding
um was not going to have any
restrictions at all
and it looks like that is now
you know wearing masks on crowded public
transport etc
is going to stay and i think that's that
is really important
just like you would in any you should do
probably in any major flu epidemic
to try and control things so doing
things that don't harm the economy
uh that that make general sense uh
keeping those going i think is important
but
we've got to start to work out how we're
going to live with this virus not keep
running away from it
well that was going to be my last
question to you tim do you think
despite their willingness to move
forward with reopening
it's been confusing messaging from
government that on the one hand they're
promising freedom day
but at the same time they were
indicating to people that perhaps they
shouldn't use
all of those freedoms and they should
still voluntarily
take many precautions or avoid crowded
spaces do you think the messaging has
been clear enough
i wouldn't have used the same messaging
the government has
and i think people are confused and
it will be that some people will still
be very frightened to leave the house
and others will think that they can do
whatever they like
and i think this is this is a potential
danger
so i would like to see better messaging
that this virus is going to be with us
for years
that we should be looking for cold-like
symptoms because we're infecting each
other because the government is still
not putting itself on the line and
saying actually things have changed
and that the five common symptoms are
just like having a bad cold headache
sore throat
runny nose sneeze
these are really important to get that
message across
as well as saying in a crowded place if
you're feeling unwell
you know the same precautions should
should carry on but let's try and get
back to normal
and i think it's it's they need to
realize that people need their education
you can't treat them
like sheep all the time and i think
giving them the latest information
that's what we've been trying to do
with the zoe app all the time and i
think uh
that would be my message to the
government is to give people the facts
tell them what the symptoms are so tell
them what their actual risks are
and let them get back to normal and that
people make their own
decisions to some extent but they should
be safe to go on public transport for
example
tim thanks for joining me
[Music]
you